[Music]
all right well hello everyone
um I'm here with my colleague Dylan and
uh we're going to kind of discuss spring
cover crop forage options you know
spring times upon us we're at mid-march
here uh temperatures are warming up and
just wanted to kind of talk through some
options so Dylan Could you um maybe walk
us through some of the different cover
crop mixes that you're putting together
for guys right now
yeah absolutely Nathan I'd be happy to
do that so I'll walk you guys I'll walk
everybody through
um kind of what I like to put together
for a pretty General uh forage mix
spring Forge mix you know there's
certainly different Uh custom mixes we
can do depending on your situation but
this is a general mix and I like to put
together
um I would start uh if you want you can
get you can get on our smart mix
calculator at
smartmix.greencoverseat.com I actually
utilize this daily because it's a really
great quote tool for me to put put
together quotes just even as a sales rep
yeah I have an account already but it'll
ask you to start an account and then you
want to go into to start a mix and from
here we'll name our mix for this one
we'll we'll call it Grandpa's uh East 40
for kind of a fun day and uh we'll call
it 40 acres worth
we're gonna have no irrigation this is
my this is my hometown zip code you can
put whatever zip code is your hometown
and from there it'll kind of calculate
average rainfall for all states
and give you a better idea of what what
species may work better in your area and
we'll go to bagging option for this
we'll put in a tote bag we are not
certified organic but if you are you can
certainly click yes you have three
different options for seating drilled
broadcast and broadcast with
incorporation and incorporation could
mean tillage maybe you're you're
spreading it for cattle to trample in
but for this example we're going to do a
drilled cover and I think probably the
next cash crop would be wheat generally
that's what most guys are going to be
getting to after spring forage mix
there's just not enough time to get a
spring cash crop in generally behind one
of these mixes especially if you're
grazing it
so we'll leave it at seating today and
just be out there for about two months
there's three different goals you can
select you're only required to select
one and that's what we'll do for now and
we'll just call it supplemental crazy a
lot of these species will will take care
of a lot of goals
um just by even focusing on on one goal
um from there uh you'll there you have
the smart mix auto adjust button if this
is your first time I would leave that on
I leave it on until I get my species
selected and then I shut it off and and
kind of adjust my my pounds from there
from there you're going to want to add
your species you've got an excellent
good marginal and risky categories
uh most generally if you're probably
staying in the excellent to good that's
probably where you need to be as we're
looking at legumes my two favorite
legumes for a a grazing mix it's going
to be spring Forge peas because
they're a great protein highly
mycorrhizal very good for the soil
really brings those mycorrhizal colonies
together and then crimson clover nice
Crimson nice Clover that will put on
pretty big leaves and a lot of tons out
there for you
when I look at grasses I look at
probably your most common spring spring
grass and that's going to be spring oats
again highly hyporizable good tonnage
high quality feed and then to kind of
fill in
um I like to find some annual rye grass
small seed but very leafy very leafy uh
texture again high quality forage can
can really bring some tons into that mix
and then when I'm selecting brassicas my
go-to is going to be kale and collards
and that's just mainly for their for
their Leaf texture very palatable Leaf
big leaf a lot of a lot of forage there
for those cattle and probably the two
broad leaves that you could select would
be flax or facilia flax cattle aren't
really going to touch which is okay
um it leaves some it leaves some residue
out there for that next cash crop again
another product
nice puts on a nice blue flower that can
contract beneficial pollinators the
facilia will do that as well if this is
going to be a haying option I would not
select flax I would go with facilia flax
you may have some issues with with hay
in that product but with this being a
grazing product we're going to select
flax
so yeah with auto mix adjust button on
it it just Auto adjusts and divides
these out evenly to to get close to 125
of a full rate so you can see the full
rate percentage here if each one is at
18 and that's that number is that number
is taking this number here divided by
the full rate of if this was planted as
a mono so three pounds of crimson clover
is 18 and then you can look over here
this gives you the details of the mix
um Acres
Acres area what it's going to be bagged
in how you're going to be drilling it or
planting it next cash crop in your
growing period and down here to pounds
and pounds per acre I don't really when
I'm making mixes I don't look at this
too much I look at the seeds per acre in
the seeds per square foot it gives me a
better idea of it helps me visualize
better what we're doing and I try to
stick around a million million and a
half seeds per acre and I think that
puts you around oh somewhere around 20
25 seeds per square foot
and this would be your mix density of of
the of the mix
and it can walk you through the full
rate of legumes grasses brassicas the
weight and the percentage of the seeds
so if I'm going to really customize this
mix this is generally a mix that I I put
together two pounds of clover about
eight pounds of spring forged peas I'll
do two pounds of rye grass and probably
anywhere from 30 to 35 pounds of Hayden
oats you know just depending on on where
you're at and your rainfall environment
when it comes to Nebraska's I like a
pound and a half of total brassicas so I
do about a pound of collards and a half
pound of kale by flax since it's not
much of a grazer just more of a soil
soil beneficiary I I put it about three
pounds
and as you can see that puts us at about
a million and a half seats per acre so
probably in a more rain-fed environment
irrigated situation this is where I'd be
um I may I may knock some of these down
a little bit just to get that seating
rate down a little bit in a drier area
but that's Nathan that's generally the
mix I like to put together any thoughts
or comments yeah I think that's really
good like you said what guys need to
consider on those seeding rates you know
their fertility their soils the the
moisture situation
um I think that million to million and a
half's kind of that sweet spot you you
uh you know the more seeds you put out
there likely the more tonnage you're
gonna get so but also the more of the
seed mix is going to cost so there's
going to be a trade-off there
um you know a couple other species I
think a lot of guys could or should
consider this time of year you know
spring barley spring triticale
those other cereal options
but I think this is good this is an
opportunity to build some soil you know
improve organic matter you know provide
that protection
um but also like you said we're
providing forage guys should should
consider you know potential hay mixes
you know hay inventories are at some
record lows in a lot of States so we're
coming out of this drought of last year
we have some moisture now you know guys
should look at opportunities to take
advantage of some of
um some of that moisture and maybe beef
up some hay inventories so yeah I think
that's that's really good and hopefully
that's helpful to uh to our customers
out there so thanks for thanks for
walking us through that all right thanks
Nathan yeah we'll see you later thanks
everyone bye